[Music]
so time then for the press preview a
first look at what is on tomorrow's
front pages it's time to see what's
making those headlines with the daily
mirror columnist susie boniface and the
spectators deputy editor freddie gray
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight very good evening to
both of you we'll take a look at those
headlines then we'll have a chat we'll
start with the times leading with hints
from the russian military that they may
be scaling back their ambitions and
instead are focusing on taking control
of eastern ukraine
and it's the same angle for the
telegraph
meanwhile the ft carries claims from the
russian military that they never
intended to take the capital kiev
the guardian focuses on the revelation
300 people were killed after the bombing
of a theater in mariopol in the
deadliest single attack since the
invasion began
here's your eye for the morning
reporting from inside the chernobyl
nuclear power plant for the first time
since it came under attack near the
start of the conflict
meanwhile the mirror splashes with calls
for pno ferris chief executive peter
hebelthwaite to resign
and the mail has words of plans by the
justice secretary dominic raab to allow
free speech to supersede all other
rights
and just to remind you that by scanning
the qr code you can see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers that while
you watch and listen to us and i'm
joined tonight by susie boniface and
freddie gray really good to see you this
evening thanks for your time this friday
susie why don't you kick things off for
us front page of the times the headline
russians retreating to eastern ukraine
this all comes because uh the kremlin is
saying the first stage of their
operation
is over and they're now going to
concentrate on the donbass
yeah for um for a government that's
basically outlaw journalism they're very
keen to talk to as many journalists as
possible and what they're saying at the
moment is that it it's all right
everybody this is exactly what we
planned this is this is what we wanted
to happen
and so that what's happened is that only
a couple of weeks ago we were being told
that there were briefings that um putin
was thinking about going all the way
across ukraine and taking the whole
thing over eventually and now that that
strategy has sort of changed and been
toned down and we're hearing that he's
actually he only wants to take the
eastern edge of ukraine and it's not
it's not that serious he's nearly done
that as is so what it actually we're
hearing here now is is actually seeing
in real time the kremlin shifting its
stated military strategy so it's nearer
a thing that it can say it has won
something and you know if you're if you
buy into game theory and the idea that
putin has to be given um a way of saving
face to de-escalate this and to retreat
back to moscow then maybe you'll be very
positive about this but i personally i
don't think him saving face is going to
help anybody in the long run we need him
to lose face and to lose the wall quite
seriously because quite plainly he's a
man who thought that russia was still a
superpower and quite plainly it's not um
there's a really fascinating detail uh
in the bottom of the the telegraph lead
here which says that um mutinous russian
soldiers are so upset at the number of
losses in their brigade they've actually
driven a tank over their own commander
chad called colonel yuri medvedev of the
37th motor rifle brigade was pictured
being taken on a stretch into hospital
having had his legs crushed now that's
not your normal kind of mutiny within
the ranks that's that's pretty serious
if the cavalry is driving tanks over
their own boss um so putin's got more
problems than he can possibly cope with
and he's already dialing it back saying
uh we're just going to take the easton
bit don't worry guys yeah quite
extraordinary if that story if that
story is true let's take a look at the
front of the uh ft freddie same story
russia says ukraine war in new phases
focus turns to donbass i mean i guess we
can't read too much into it but the
facts are there aren't they kiev wasn't
taken in in four days as many assumed it
would be many many russian soldiers uh
are dead i mean do you think on the face
of it this is good news and that russia
won't push on to the likes of kiev now
i think it's certainly good news in the
sense that uh the russians are now sort
of
not exactly admitting but they're
they're talking a different language
um and it seems now they've said they're
saying
ft front page they're saying that they
never had any intention of taking kiev
i'm not sure we should be entirely
skeptical about that i mean it is odd
that the huge convoy did not immediately
crack on into kiev it could have been a
sort of a gesture within the wall
um but there's there's no denying the
the plan b seems to be what's in action
for for russia at the moment and that's
good news the bad news is that they're
not giving up on demilitarization which
is the
going to be the real sticking point in
any negotiations because the ukrainians
are never going to agree to
demilitarization and if they don't do
that the russians might not give up
either so i don't think we're seeing the
off-ramp for putin that some people hope
that it might be yeah and of course um
susie there is also the specter of
chemical biological even even nuclear
warfare so sort of still hanging over us
isn't there
there isn't there's also that the
spectacle of a real accident as well the
front of the eye tonight is reporting
that um those who are in the engineers
who are inside the chernobyl nuclear
plant which of course is basically a
dome now it's contained a lot of
radiation within that from 1986 and it's
had further sort of spent fuel rods from
decommissioned nuclear power plants put
in there they're reporting that from
these people who are inside there under
sort of russian control as it were that
they're operating on 24-hour shifts
anybody who saw the chernobyl
documentary will know full well that um
that explosion was a combination of you
know bad technical design of the reactor
and human error the last thing you want
when it comes to monitoring um nuclear
active power plants is is people who are
doing 24-hour shifts and are too tired
to be doing a proper job so it's really
safe yeah and freddie you've written a
comment piece uh for tomorrow about joe
biden tell us about this
well i mean uh there's been a lot of uh
sort of doubt cast about joe biden um
you know a lot of talk about how he's
leading from behind and he's not showing
the kind of leadership
that we want and this trip to europe
rather hastily organized trip to europe
uh has been supposed to show that he's
on the front foot
uh he's dealing with the humanitarian
crisis he's
stiffening up nato and so on uh but of
course joe biden being joe biden uh
there are gas aplenty that pizza that
you so you showed him eating earlier he
then was sort of almost choked on it
because it had very spicy jalapenos
and then today he told the 82nd airborne
division
um that when they go into ukraine
they're going to see women standing
women and men standing in front of tanks
and of course he's not supposed to be
sending troops into ukraine it was a
very odd thing to say he seemed to be
just letting his mouth
run away with him
uh and this is one of my big hobby
horses of the last few years is that
biden's mouth is is actually a problem
because he doesn't seem to have any idea
what he's saying a lot of the time
um and in these very very serious times
with potentially world war iii breaking
out uh you need
clarity from your leaders uh the worry
is that biden isn't providing that i'm
not saying that i think he should be all
sort of you know tough and in every way
possible and threatening
russia with some nuclear war as some
people seem to want him to do
i just think we need him to be coherent
uh and we don't have that okay susie
just in a sentence how do you feel the
president has fared during this crisis
um i think
all of those things may be fair
criticism of joe biden if you were
comparing him to
um perhaps barack obama you compare him
to donald trump he's an absolute joy
okay all right we'll leave it there for
the moment uh thank you both uh still to
come uh plenty more uh uh from the
papers including more woes for piano
ferries as one of their vessels is
detained we'll tell you about that in a
moment
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview susie
and freddie still with us uh front page
of the mirror susie the papers printed
before the the breaking news uh this
evening that one of the piano ferries
has been detained in lan the european
causeway detained because of uh problems
with crew familiarization vessel
documentation crew training as well it's
pretty serious stuff the piano in the
front of the mirror is saying sling your
hook to the boss
yep and the mirrors called for a number
of people to to
leading organizations to sling their
hook because they're incompetent the
last one i think was the prime minister
who today is saying that the boss of
piano should go um but this is the same
prime minister of course who said that
his own incompetence and record didn't
mean that he should go
so it's interesting but um it kind of
it's bizarre really to to hear a
conservative prime minister particularly
boris johnson but to hear a conservative
prime minister demanding the boss of a
company go someone who earns two three
times what the pm does
um on the grounds that he's fired lots
of people that's something you'd expect
to hear from a labour prime minister
perhaps but really not a conservative
one so it's interesting
he's intentionally broken the law he's
considered what the law is and then
according to his evidence to the select
committee this week he then decided not
to bother following the law because it
was too much of a pain um so you know we
could all buy that in mind and try with
that if we come up for the magistrate
for something or other and see if we use
that as a defense and if it works um he
should obviously be investigated and
face the penalties for for the offences
that he's committed it does seem to be
some um but i think it's you know the
front of the star has got a great front
page about how an ocean going burke has
told motion going burke that they're no
longer wanted and should walk the plank
and talks about brass neck or harmy
hearties it's a great style front page
um so we'll just have to see which book
goes first won't we yeah and freddie i
mean
this has been a a huge pr disaster for
pno i mean it's all on all the front
pages today
um it's been been a terrible week and it
could have been handled so much better
well they've obviously got it completely
wrong but the times are against uh a lot
of these sorts of companies and and i
realize this is not a story about
oligarchs and yachts although every time
i see the pictures on it i think the
ferry is a yacht because we got so used
to seeing pictures of
of uh grubby russians with their yachts
the interesting
well hold on there is an interesting
parallel here because when uh piano was
bought in 2006 by sultan sullivan um you
know it was seen as another great
example of confidence in british
business of the global economy working
really really well
now it's seen as a typically badly
organized company skimming profits
treating its staff terribly
and another british a great british
asset that has been sort of sold out to
the globalized economy so there is
an interesting parallel there about the
way we're thinking about
money coming to this country and
particularly big money from very rich
people that we probably don't trust yeah
it would be interesting to see how all
this plays out the uh
maritime and coast guard agency uh
tonight saying the vessel will remain
under detention until all these issues
are resolved by piano ferries only then
will it be re-inspected detention of
ships is based on concerns over their
safety and to prevent them going to see